and now to some breaking news uh in the
last hour sky news has confirmed that
premier league giants manchester united
and liverpool are planning a major
overhaul of that top flight football it
could see
the biggest change to the league in a
generation while sky's
in the newsroom for us so tell us more
now well um we're still getting the
details at the moment and getting our
heads around these new plans so it's the
biggest shake-up since
1992 we know liverpool have proposed
they've made these proposals and
manchester united
are also backing them and i'll try and
go through the details and give you a
sense of what these proposals may
include we understand that talks have
been ongoing since 2017
but have but have accelerated in light
of the pandemic and we obviously know a
lot of clubs have been in crisis
since the coronavirus uh pandemic which
has affected
society and so many businesses um today
well we know manchester united and
liverpool are the main players and
they're proposing to cut the size of the
premier league
down to 18 from at 20
and essentially this will mean handing
the controls to the biggest clubs
over decisions and relegations and
changes
so nine clubs who've been in the premier
league for the longest would then
dictate the running
of the league and the document also
proposes an 18-team league
the accident of the league cup and
additional funding
being made available for the football
league and in exchange
250 million pound rescue
package for the football league to help
through the coveted pandemic
at the moment so in a nutshell those are
the plans and
from what we've seen so far the reaction
has been uh mostly positive
people welcoming those in the football
world i should say welcoming these
proposals which could
move so many clubs who are struggling at
the moment financially
in a better place